turning back to the u.s florida's gulf
coast is being hit hard this summer by
what's known as a red tide an
algae bloom that can kill fish and make
it hard for humans to breathe
it stretches nearly a hundred miles
along the state's west coast
and is hurting businesses during the
peak of the summer tourism season
environmental correspondent ben tracy
got an up close look
at the worst effects dude this is nuts
local fishermen are documenting the
devastation from the red
tide that has washed over tampa bay this
is an
absolute nightmare tyler cappella runs a
fishing charter business
he took us out on the water to see it
for ourselves
that was a nice big beautiful cobia
dead fish everywhere killed by the
massive algae bloom that has at times
turned the water toxic
scared away tourists and appears to be
forcing these baby sharks
to swim up canals fleeing for their
lives
what is this meant for your business
that's 12 1500 bucks a day in my pocket
and now i'm doing zero
cappella even covered himself in dead
fish
and posted it on instagram to raise
awareness
i have your attention now
[Applause]
many floridians are worried not just
about their waterways
but also their own airways there are
days that i can't walk to the end of my
street
because i'm already coughing red tides
do naturally occur
here but scientists believe warming
ocean waters due to climate change
may be making them more frequent this
spring a breach at an old phosphate pit
sent more than 200 million gallons of
polluted water
into tampa bay the last severe red tide
bloom was just three years ago we would
have expected 10 years to go by before
we see something like this tyler capela
fears red tides will eventually
sink his business are you worried about
your livelihood
oh 100 percent and eventually the whole
area is going to become a dead zone
for cbs this morning ben tracy tampa bay